in this morning's high on money we are
looking at key financial and tax savings
moves
to consider with just 44 days left in
2020
the pandemic has devastated the economy
of course and parts of the cares act
which provided financial relief will
expire on december 31st some of those
emergency measures including stimulus
payments and
extended unemployment benefits could add
to confusion in the upcoming tax season
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us now
with what you need to know jill good
morning you say
i need to be thinking about taxis and
now why
well as you said with just 44 days left
there aren't that many things you can do
after the year passes so the most
important thing to remember is part of
the cares act
is really causing people to worry your
economic stimulus checks
they are not taxable so you don't need
to really fret about that
however millions of americans receive
some form of unemployment throughout
2020
whether it's a federal or a state
program that is
taxable and wide majority of people did
not withhold taxes
based on that so here's what you need to
do you go to the irs website irs.gov
go to the withholding estimator see if
you can
change your estimates or potentially
make a payment
so you have no penalty or surprises in
april
again really important for everyone
especially for those
who received unemployment benefits and
did not withhold
five americans worked from home are
there tax considerations
if you worked in a different state
yeah this is a very strange quirk of
this particular recession because so
many people
did go out of state a lot of younger
adults went back with their families
well this could be a benefit but it
could be a problem as well
so what you need to do is compile the
number of days throughout the year
that you worked in your primary location
then the days that you worked
elsewhere now this could also include
not just a different state it might be a
different jurisdiction you might live
in new york city as your primary and you
moved upstate and you don't have to pay
new york city tax potentially
so you compile those days then you check
with your location where you
your primary residence is see what the
rules are
and then you may want to adjust your
withholding accordingly
but again a little bit of homework for
you it could pay off
uh jill how do you know what you're able
to deduct for a home office and so many
people were working
from home this may have been
the number one question i received on my
podcast i can't wait till i get to april
so i can deduct
everything that i've done not so fast
here's why
when we had a tax cut in 2017 that
basically erased the ability for an
employee to deduct the home office
expense or any miscellaneous business
expenses
now that said if you're self-employed if
you're a gig worker
you may be able to deduct your rent or
your mortgage your property taxes
you really have to make sure that you
comply with the irs rules has to be
regular use of your location or even
partial location
and of course you cannot be a pig don't
say
everything is for work check with your
irs rules please because it is an audit
flag yeah
that's not a trigger my accountant
always told me jill thank you very much
we appreciate it